Ukraine's defense minister has one thing
on his mind what do you expect from NATO
today
he's visiting
ala very different but just as vital
front line here at NATO's headquarters
in Brussels
pledges of weapons from the West are
crucial for Ukraine to fight Russia's
invasion
and the need is growing as President
Vladimir Putin escalates his war with
new attacks Putin has given us all
another Grim preview of a future
in which the appetites of aggressive
autocrats outweigh the rights of
peaceful States the perfectly on air
defense systems given the need from
Ukraine why are Western allies not
sending these systems in Faster is it
because of a lack of political will or a
lack of supplies
well certainly is not a question of lack
of will
the commitment the resolve that the
chairman and I witnessed in this contact
group beating today
was inspiring and that's what I told the
members of the group they they remain
committed to doing everything they can
to generate additional capabilities but
a senior Diplomat told Sky News limited
Western stockpiles are affecting what
can be given to Ukraine
Germany is stepping up but with just one
air defense system now and three more
next year in advance
on the battlefield Ukrainian forces are
reliant on Western weapons
[Applause]
like this British rocket launcher
yet NATO allies have reduced stockpiles
of their own military kit and ammunition
to save money following the end of the
Cold War Russia's Invasion has belatedly
forced to rethink but it takes time to
replenish stores and time isn't on
Ukraine's side
[Music]
Putin speaking at an energy Forum will
also be feeling the strain but is
showing no sign of giving up the West
will surely be hoping his weapons run
out before theirs do debraham Sky News
Brussels